[Music]
all right and we all love Lourdes gaming
dotnet I love podcasting the building
Lord saw fresh out of the ubisoft press
conference lord soft man what did you
think of Ubisoft this is becoming a bit
of a broken record I was I was not happy
with you we saw the press conference I
mean basically the watchdogs looked
amazing right the way they are evolving
the watchdogs formula the fact that you
can use pretty much anybody in the world
any NPC can become a playable character
all of them have different traits
different attributes you can make a
brawler you can make somebody who was a
former mi6 agent you can even take
little old ladies your granny Sun the
granny Sun that was fantastic I think
watchdogs looks looks great and they're
building upon a lot of the stuff that
was great about watchdogs to break point
looked good I like the fact what they've
added to Rainbow six siege then they
talked about the new Rainbow six game
yes quarantine quarantine quarantine
this is gonna be just a multiplayer
co-op PvE experience so maybe this might
be something maybe I can get in that
selfish game but all in all I don't in
terms of new stuff again for me III is
big you need to drop the mic and it just
seemed like very pedestrian very safe
not too much new stuff that they talked
about so disappointed I was hoping to
see maybe another Nintendo collaboration
maybe some stuff with X cloud and when I
know they talk a little bit of beta this
is luminous and I was luminescent is in
the building so so that was cool but
again I just think I just think it was
underwhelming um the you play Plus
yeah it's all about encryption thing did
not sit right with me because the price
point is $15 a month you do get access
to all the new games but it's PC only
and at this point they sort of touted
their there long library of games right
the years but they're only starting out
with a hundred plus games so it's a
little weird to me I would think you'd
be ready to go with that and have your
entire archive in there $15 a month is a
little steep especially when you start
comparing it to you know act you know a
game pass ultimate and things of that
nature
yeah so again underwhelming but it was
cool to be here yeah I mean I think we
kind of on the same page I think they
started off pretty strong I mean
obviously to get the game for me was
washed off legions I wanted to see how
that was gonna play out the NPC's being
able to pick the characters choose
between each having and recruiting your
own resistance
I loved the backdrop of London so I'm
biased I got fan out this UK fan
Piccadilly circles looking nice I'm just
I'm just saying
looking really crispy blokes out there
but up now I mean other than that you
know breakpoint we kind of knew already
but I'm a sucker for John Burrell burnt
all shout - shame you know I'm saying
Walking Dead The Punisher so I think
he's perfectly cast I loved I didn't
really show much you knew it was just
more story stuff other than that I would
agree at that point when one just days
came out it was in the bushes for me
that part I know MJ the boss might have
been throwing it up but it's like they
showing out a little too hard and it's
like we get it if it's successful you
guys great you don't I don't need to see
it as much as I need I didn't need to
Club the bus out you know in the
conference but that's me um as far as
that or gods and monsters I didn't know
what that really was
I believe I saw a leak about that
indicating that was some sort of like
some kind of a Zelda like type V show a
little bit of a trailer and not much of
anything else so again I want to see
what that is I would say this I will say
the UM the rainbow six quarantine as a
separate game Peevy only and I want to
see what's going on with that mechanic
of him like injecting himself
you seem to be fighting some type of
virus thing that seemed interesting to
me very interesting because you know
last week a week before when they
indicated like it felt like they were
saying Rainbow six would only be siege
from now on right and what they've meant
by that was like quote siege is not
getting a sequel she was gonna keep
getting expanded upon right but that
doesn't mean we're not making it more
Rainbow six and and doing different
things to Rainbow six I was happy to see
that yeah I think I think I do agree
with solved oh they did drop the ball
with the Ubisoft subscription was it you
play what is it called
plus you play plus alright here's the
thing you charge you $15 and your PC
only right so that exclusivity you just
eliminate a console that I think in my
pen would be interesting and then we
have game pass ultimate fifteen bucks
that's combining all that an Xbox Live
Gold so as far as value Xbox is really
superseding this service now I know PC
guys will buy this and that's
interesting oh shout out I want to
mention the Division two they talked
about a new raid they talked about
depending on some story missions seem
cool I would love them to balance their
raids but that's another story
but um maybe like one or two other games
that kind of stood out maybe it was like
a platformer kind of gay Oh
the rollerblade was a little weird
little weird but I will be testing that
out once we get back to the complex file
on the field gonna have Sam Fisher in a
mobile game that's disrespectful though
where is to the point where like Loki
Ubisoft is trolling like they're
trolling they party enough doing doing
say hey we can't be doing this in tweet
some mobile RTS game like come on like
Splinter Cell fans our feeling look
disrespected right now you don't say and
the last one I will say I did notice
their commitment to stadia they're very
evident in a lot of these trailers to
keep pushing that narrative to keep
saying streaming in that partnership
with Google now be honest with you like
Ubisoft are the ones that are always
first in line to support anything new
yes so I don't see that being any
different with with X cloud once X
naught is really out there right so do
but do you think they because of this
partnership they may exclude X cloud
okay do you think
they'll eventually partner what Xbox
with their game see that's one thing
that remains to be seen with all these
streaming platforms now and more
services out there it remains to be seen
where the battle lines are gonna be
drawn and if people are going to be
inclusive in this sort of stuff or it's
gonna be like a council war right so
it's gonna be interesting to see where
the lines are drawn when it comes to
this cloud stuff yeah absolutely I mean
I found a point with that is just like I
said I just find it interesting that
they you know the camera focus don't
fail
they're always making it their business
you know making it their business to
emphasize that partnership so to me
again I could be looking more into it it
feels exclusive but again it just could
be that their first and like you said
will be someone to jump ahead their
first to kind of throw their face
anything it would be weird to not have
too much Exploud information that Xbox
the press conference and then get more
details at this one exactly so again it
may just not be ready yet and but I
again Ubisoft supports everyone all the
time absolutely yeah so that's pretty
much it man
my little podcast Lords of gaming dotnet
we just came out of Ubisoft busy busy
day with your PC gaming but we already
talked about talked about as well no we
didn't get to do that yet we're running
back and forth running around but yo
shout out till Ubisoft for the event and
that was here I am the podcast you
already know in the building and we out